[Music]
so just a little tidbit fact on the day
that the Super Bowl was played okay okay
you realize that's a bad day to be a
chicken wings and think I'm just saying
uh-huh I'm just saying okay what Oh guys
so but in fact any day in America is a
bad day to be a chicken Americans
consume on average about a million
chickens per hour oh the chicken is the
most slaughtered animal in all of the
history of Agriculture Wow yeah it's a
good thing that I don't have any
feelings for chickens they are delicious
and I just blame chickens for being so
delicious it's not my problem but so how
much chicken is consumed in in the form
of wings because that's the Superbowl is
probably the day that more wings than
any other day in the world I know so all
these like sort of you know wingless
chickens wandering around laundering
walking around definitely walking it was
an exclusive interview on play the
people who can't see but got a rubber
chicken who rubber chicken and once he
heard Neil's stat this is what he had to
say in Houston so I got another another
related statistics so you know cuz I
don't think that chicken could take
anymore
so in the United States we consume 8,500
whole chickens every 30 seconds whole
chickens every 30 SEC's we consume 8,500
chickens every 30 seconds in the United
States you are horrifying my friend
all right just more data for you I don't
know what you know I love it that's all
there's waiting for you to say I'm gonna
digest those numbers but we're gonna
move on
very cool very cute yeah you can find
playing with science wherever you listen
to podcasts on stitcher radio iTunes
podcast google play music SoundCloud and
tune in new shows premiere every
Wednesday night at 7 p.m. Eastern
subscribe now and don't miss a single
science filled episode oh we just not
just went out depart baby